hier sur notre plateau jean marie bigard
était invité pour revenir sur les
nombreuses déclarations qu'il avait
faites au sujet du gouvernement ou
encore du corona virus un virus autour
duquel ils pressent un complot il ya
trois milliards et demi qui ne sont que
des estomacs à remplir
ils ne font rien marché et sans eux les
riches seront encore plus l'humoriste
est aussi revenu sur une conversation
qu'il aurait eue avec le président
emmanuel macron au sujet de la
chloroquine j'ai dit franchement
présidence italienne avio ce qu'est ce
tu fais tu fais le traitement du
professeur out et m'a dit oui depuis ses
révélations jean marie bigard raconte
être totalement censuré des réseaux
sociaux c'est plus subtil que ça on me
coupe carrément pendant 48 heures pire
il affirme être la tête à abattre dans
ce pays kosciuszko gueule on te coupe la
tête
une intervention qui n'a pas manqué de
faire réagir les téléspectateurs aussi
bien en le soutenant en déplorant le
spectacle auquel il s'est donné alors
êtes vous d'accord avec les propos de
jean-marie bigard il ya dans tpm p ce
soir sa femme lola marois est avec nous
et merci lola d'être avec nous
magnifique
lola marois qui était avec nous qu'il
veut qu'ils voulaient venir nous voir
aujourd'hui et nous donner son point de
vue sur ce qui s'est passé hier
alors c'est vrai que hier jean-marie on
l'a tous différents vous l'adorent mais
c'est vrai que vous avez été aussi et
tout ça un peu dur avec lui êtes vous
d'accord avec les propos de jean-marie
bigard hier dans tpm p est-ce que vous
avez parlé avec jean marie puis hier est
ce que quand il est revenu il était de
dents dans quelles dispositions
jean-marie évidemment en a parlé c'est
mon mari j'habitais avec link sera t il
celui où par des couacs ce qui est un
soutien
en fait il était dans des dispositions
assez bonne parce que il sait qu'il
avait quand même une grande partie des
français qui continuait à penser qu'il
devait s'exprimer
d'accord qu'importe juin voilà le
contenu mais en tout cas qu'il avait le
droit de le faire
ensuite quelqu'un d' extrêmement
sensible donc il était un petit peu
ébranlé par évidemment les oppositions
des chroniqueurs mais en même temps
c'est pas un enfant non plus donc il
savait qu'il allait peut-être recevoir
quelques coups et puis quand canton et
lui et qu on dit comme ça tout ce que
certains pensent peut-être tout bas on
s'attend à avoir quelques représailles
ce normal alors qu'est ce qu'il va dire
aux chroniqueurs ce soit parce que je
sais que vous avez regardé l'émission un
gars je sais que vous les avez trouvé
dur pour la plupart mois en fait ce que
je voudrais vous dire à tous déjà c'est
que si vous êtes ici c'est que vous êtes
des gens intelligents alors la balle est
déjà à partir on va partir ce possible
transfert de ce postulat alors et voilà
pour la plupart je vous connais je
trouve sympathique et j'ai aucun souci
avec vous maintenant je trouve que vous
avez tout à fait le droit de ne pas être
d'accord avec ces propos c'est
précisément ce que je viens défendre ce
soir c'est à dire une liberté
d'expression une liberté de pensée et
avoir le droit de dire je suis pas
d'accord du tout avec ce que vous
racontez
marie ça c'est absolument évident en
revanche c'était pas vous qui étiez dur
c'était le phénomène de masse qui a un
petit peu c'est seul contre tous je
pense c'est que mon opinion de jeunes
femmes artistes
alors je suis une amoureuse ses
amoureuses et j'aime mon mari évidemment
mais je pense que le tort en fait de
jean marie c'est d'arriver avec des
certitudes
il vient ici avec une sorte de vérité
absolue que même des scientifiques qui
voilà qui sont sur ces recherches a
depuis 50 ans non même pas donc en fait
évidemment eu envie de lui dire jean
marie comment tu peux être aussi sûr de
ce que tu avances
donc je pense que le tort en fait qu'à
mon mari c'est surtout sur la forme pas
vraiment sur le fond nous pondent succès
si près que je ne cautionne pas parce
qu'on pensait comme lui alors non non je
ne pense pas comme lui
gênant lorsqu'on va voir on va voir
juste voilà hier que jean marie y voilà
on va voir si on va revenir sur trois
déclarations d'omar sy dire regardez par
exemple il ya celle ci il a surpris hier
en disant voilà regarder routier dense à
1103 des complotistes pour moi sont des
collabos accepté
est-ce que clairement vous reprochez
vous accuser notre gouvernement donc
d'être à la solde des labos
pharmaceutiques
c'est pas ça c'est sûr et certain 9
milliards par an pour nick pharma et on
écrire ils veulent sur le trône
si vous que tu connais pas les poules le
pouvoir de l'argent il faut bien que
tout le monde est à la solde de
l'industrie pharmaceutique qui tout le
monde
alors évidemment en fait il est très
radical dans ce qu'il dit donc c'est
choquant puisqu'il dit des choses qui ne
suscite on a l'impression qu'on ne peut
pas le contredire
il est comme ça à la maison même sur des
sujets bien sûr et c'est quelque chose
que je reproche souvent c'est que quand
il dit quelque chose on a important
qu'il a la science infuse
en tout cas qu'ils croient l'avoir donc
c'est agaçant ceci dit il a le droit de
s'exprimer il a le droit de venir dire
ça ici il a le droit de le penser même
si ses propos fun vous choquer et il a
le droit de venir le dire alors mais
attendez je vous il ya des gens et il
chante et ouais voilà s'il vous plaisir
et de juste je voudrais terminer à ceci
près que sa forme est pas agréable
on a l'impression qui vient dire quelque
chose qu'il sait de source sûre donc on
a envie de lui dire mais enfin
jean-marie d'où tu sors ça maintenant
c'est un justicier dans l'âme
c'est un amoureux de la vérité de sa
vérité il pense il est intimement
convaincu qu'il dit vrai quand il dit ça
il est pas dans un délire ne croyez pas
il est sain de corps et d'esprit surtout
en ce moment
il doit pour lui depuis un mois est ce
que vous m'avez donc ce que je veux
c'est la lola c'est un justicier qui est
un amoureux de la vérité est que quand
il dit ça il croit en sa vérité non mais
on sait il a droit à ce que tu veux
ça c'est bien vous devez secours c'est
jusqu'au boutiste et il a le droit
d'avoir ses convictions et de les dire
parce qu'on est en france où le compte y
est ça c'est ce qu'il a dit jean marc il
a dit que pour lui ce considéré comme un
héros quand il faisait ça est ce que
vous considérez comme un héros il a dit
ça ou c'est bon cela dit ouais mais
c'est très bien c'est pas moi je le
considère comme un héros c'est marie je
laime pas non je suis pourquoi je
considère pas comme un héros vous savez
en quoi ces héroïques ce qu'il fait
c'est que même s'il a tort même si je ne
cautionne pas ce qu'il pense parce que
moi je ne suis absolument pas dans une
théorie du complot faut le savoir
vraiment j'ai tendance à faire confiance
à nos scientifiques et même à notre
gouvernement
je pars du principe qu'il le faut sinon
on se suicide tous collectivement mais
pour autant il a en tout cas
l'audace de venir ici et de dire ce
qu'il planche je dis ça c'est assez
héroïque face à tout le monde lui tire
dessus et c'est çà il prend des risques
il alla il n'a pas besoin c'est vrai
qu'il avait dit il n'est pas obligé de
l'armée c'est vrai que il prend des
risques en faisant ça ça veut dire que
j'approuve la sincérité mine de rien ça
l'image qu'on soit d'accord avec eux
mêmes seulement il a il a une sincérité
voilà jean marie voilà qu'on peut pas
lui enlever on sait quelqu'un est
sincère et c'est quelqu'un voilà qui ne
jouent pas qu'ici pas voilà donc ça ça
pour moi déjà c'est déjà beaucoup
juste on va parler de la conversation
téléphonique il avec le président
emmanuel macron qui nous a révélé mais
justement delphine wespiser vous d'être
la seule à dire oui vous êtes d'accord
avec jean marie bigard est ce qu'il va
dire oui j'ai regardé l'émission hier et
c'est vrai que je vous ai je vous ai un
peu dur je vous ai trouvé un peu dire
parce qu'au final il y avait que
guillaume qui était à peu près mitigé et
généralement ici on représente bien la
proportion des français et je suis sûr
qu'il ya beaucoup plus de français qui
se questionne aussi parce que c'est
légitime parce que même les gens au plus
haut point de l'état ne savent pas
certains médecins se contredisent donc
c'est normal aujourd'hui on veut faire
comme ça a été des moutons aller dans un
même sens alors qu'on n'a pas de vrai
berger donc c'est normal qu'on veut
analyser qu'on se questionne lalanne il
est venu il se questionne jean marie
bigard il est venu face à tout six
questionne et mon chéri on était
ensemble un canapé il m'a dit qu'est ce
qui fait il en train de se tirer une
balle dans le pied
nico il était d'accord avec toi je dis
bah non pas du tout un quelqu'un qui
fait de la télé peut être engagée aussi
ça veut dire que c'est un artiste qui
est complet et qui a des valeurs et qui
va pas dans le sens des moutons il a le
droit de se questionner personne n'a la
rivière l'eure vers sarlat où delphine
d'accord ok et merci beaucoup au passage
delphine mais là où tu as raison c'est
que en fait on est tellement tous
on navigue un peu à vue quand même
depuis cette crise sanitaire on navigue
à vue on a beau dire personne n'a des
vraies réponses
personne n'est sûr à 100% que ce vaccin
on a suffisamment de recul je suis
désolé personne ne peut dire à 100% que
le mélange deux hits romy cinedigm et
diderot xi chloroquine pris à temps
début de symptôme n'était pas peut-être
une solution dont rangs féminins baisser
la charge virale non mais on n'en a pas
la preuve par a plus b que ça ne pouvait
pas baisser un petit peu la charge
virale ce duo de médicaments après il a
été démontré que des lidd roxy
chloroquine n'était pas du tout efficace
sur la charge et ratu sonnerie journée
on a posé des questions et se
questionnent mollahs sur l'île de kodiak
finalement cccc sur un an
c'est ce qu'a fait le plus réagir c'est
cette histoire avec emmanuel macron jean
marie bigard est également revenu sur la
discussion qu'il avait eu au téléphone
avec emmanuel macron il ya quelques
temps et qui avait notamment pour sujet
l'hydroxyde chloroquine alors regardez
cet extrait et vous allez nous dire si
vous étiez à côté de lui et si vous
cautionnez qu'il ait révélé cette
conversation entre lui et le président
regarde mais franchement président un
coup d'oeil mais peuvent si tu as le
site alcoa n'avions eu ce qu'est ce tu
fais tu fais le traitement du professeur
out et il m'a dit oui mais c'était quand
cet appel je le jure pardon non mais
quand cet appel c'est ben c'était aux
avancées avant qu'il ait d'abord le
round c'est à la mode quand il était à
marseille pour voir le professeur raoul
bien avoir encore y en avait avant les
études en fait il s'en fout je sais pas
s'il fait le traitement ou pas ce que je
sais c'est que beaucoup de députés qui
se soigne à l'hydraulique l'euro qui
s'est déjà suffisant pour être
insupportable alors on passe à la
dernière partie de thé bmp et vous allez
me dire si vous étiez au courant de
cette conversation c'est parti
[Musique]
alors lola est ce que vous étiez un côté
but quand le président lui a parlé oui
j'ai pas envie de m'étendre sur ce sujet
là mais je peux vous dire que oui
j'étais là j'ai tjrs un coup ces tirs
côté lui donc vous avez voilà est-ce que
vous cautionnez que mon mari est ce que
vous comprenez qu'il l'ait dit qu'il ait
révélé cette conversation parce que je
crois que c'est ça qui a agacé le
président va pas se mentir on sait mais
est ce que c est ce que c'est grave
d'agacer le président dites moi non mais
on pense que c'est ça puisqu'ils doivent
lui met des bâtons dans les roues etc
c'est ce qu'il l'est semblait dire mais
c'est pas le président qui lui met des
bâtons dans les roues c'est la censure
qui fait que deux sur facebook il arrive
plus trop à s'exprimer je pense pas que
ça soit les ça vienne et ça vient pas du
président que porte parole du
gouvernement et dit quoi là dessus non
évidemment que ça vient pas du tout du
précédent le président s'en fout mais il
a d'ailleurs absolument pas réagi aux
propos de monsieur biya et puisqu'ils
s'en fout non on s'en fout pas bien du
tout été le président soit réagi aux
propos seul truc que moi j'ai rappelé
simplement c'est que lors de l'entretien
du 14 juillet tel entretien traditionnel
on lui a posé la question à savoir
avez-vous et si jamais vous êtes
atteints par cette virus allez vous être
traités avec l'hydroxyde l'origine il a
dit très clairement non voilà donc c'est
clair
voilà d'accord mais là il avait dit très
clairement oui mais non mais c'était
bien avant c'est jean marie c'est ce que
je vous dis il a plusieurs trains godard
- globalement hier j'étais pas du tout
d'accord avec ce qu'il disait mais pour
autant je n'étais pas du tout pour la
censure et alors que beaucoup de mes
camarades n'étaient pas pour la censure
donc évidemment la liberté d'expression
et moi je j'aime beaucoup combattre les
idées de jean marie bigard ça c'est la
première chose deuxième chose je vous
trouve incroyable en décodeurs de votre
mari je trouve que vous êtes affaires de
partenaires levier de combat merci ces
modèles magistrale et voilà sa montre il
ya beaucoup journée pour le compliment
c'est ça il a il a beaucoup de chance de
vous avoir peut-être que vous en avez de
l'avoir violée j'en ai juste jeu
jean-marie il est il et comment là
aujourd'hui mais il est bien jean marie
l'écho mais laissons il est content
d'eux il est content de ce qui s'est dit
sur les réseaux parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui étaient d'accord avec lui
aussi jean-marie les fidèles à lui même
il est contente d'elle
d'être allé jusqu'au bout de ses idées
d'avoir pu les exprimer chez vous et en
ça vous êtes aussi courageux de
l'accueillir et de laisser s'exprimer
oui mais au delà with a voulu laisser la
parole je voudrais bien et à côté de ça
il sait que les français l'encouragent à
continuer à s'exprimer que pour autant
même si on n'a pas d'idée complotistes
ont il ya une grosse partie qui est
entre les collabos comme il les appelle
et les complotistes cds français qui se
posent des questions mais vous traitez
des français qui nous posent des
questions là il est quand même jusqu'au
boutiste aujourd'hui il est dans une
sorte de posture alors je sais pas si
c'est une fille je artistique nommé ses
sincères mais il a essayé les gilet
jaune ça n'a pas marché du marché mais
non je peux je peux pas vous laisser
dire que justicier pour un artiste avant
tournebride elle a envie de l'entendre
parler à leur écoute et vous n'avez pas
envie c'est une chance je vous comprends
moi même plus j'ai pas envie ça me
saoule
ça me galles mais peut-être des certains
mais peut-être que ce faire mais je ne
peux pas l'arrêter dansez dansez dansez
kate et dans ses recherches et dans ces
combats qui je suis pour l'arrêter dans
ces combats
maintenant je vais juste vous dire
quelque chose ça fait aussi partie de
lui c'est sa manière aussi après de
venir faire de l'humour sur scène et
d'être galvanisés par une sorte de quête
de vérité et de rester vivant il n'est
pas monté sur scène depuis un an
si les artistes pouvaient remonter sur
scène il aura peut être moins de temps à
jouer les scientifiques et les
justiciers son temps mais pour autant
ses convictions aujourd'hui et les
questions qu'ils se posent sur les
éventuels traitements de laisser agir
les médecins traitants tout ce qu'il a
dit hier il le pense je pense
et ma foi pourquoi arrêter un artiste
qui a des idées au même si on les
partage pas si vous êtes une magnifique
avocate de ce qu'a dit jean marie hier
et franchement non mais c'est vrai à à
vous entendre on sent ce qu'il a pu
éprouver c'est-à-dire qui s'est retrouvé
face à des gens dont moi qui ne regrette
pas mais qui était très hostile à ces
théories
néanmoins si vous êtes là si vous êtes
avocate avec l'intelligence subtil
jean-marie est-ce que c'est pas aussi
parce qu'ils se dit aujourd'hui et que
vous vous êtes dit il faut que j'y aille
parce qu'il a quand même dépassé les
bornes châtelain de soins
ses convictions mais il ya des points
sur les très loin gilles oui il est
comme ça il va très loin tout le temps
depuis toute sa vie il mourra comme ça
il a 66 ans on ne le changera pas je
peux vous dire deux choses la première
déjà c'est que voilà je suis venu parce
qu'on me l'a demandé que j'avais envie
de venir aussi me prononcer sur ce sujet
c'est pas moi de mon propre fête qui me
suis dit je vais aller alimenter cette
polémique parce que j'ai pas que ça à
faire
et deuxièmement jean marie est ressorti
d'ici encore plus les terres fort plus
grand et plus déterminé ma foi a pas
grand chance parce qu'il va rien faire
duo de voix là ça n'est qu'un artiste et
donc il n'est pas déterminé à faire quoi
que ce soit il s'en va pas dans un
combat dans une bataille mais avec ses
convictions et voyant qu'il allait
français qui l'encouragent à continuer à
se questionner et à réfléchir
il est sorti fort est grand et il est
content parce qu'il voit qu'il a une
grande partie des français qui en ont
marre un petit peu d'être voit la balade
est bousculé dans tous les sens on est
quand même très ébranlée on sait on sait
plus trop ce qui nous arrive tous autant
que leur nez et on n'a pas de réponse
sûre et certaine noblesse ans et sont
contents de voir un artiste qui se
questionnent et qui questionne les gens
mais il n'a pas la forme ça je suis
d'accord à exemple lola lola lafon
vous avez peur pour lui voilà exactement
ce qu'on a vu l'épisode avec les choses
dans la vie
les gilet jaune il y est allé il s'est
pris une petite branlée pas très pathé
violent parce que vous avez déjà eu peur
pour lui vraiment et en ce moment est ce
que vous avez peur pour lui moi si j'ai
peur pour lui c'est pour d'autres choses
j'ai peur pour lui s'il boit trop j'ai
peur pour lui quand il crie trop fort
parce que j'ai peur qu'il se fasse péter
une une veine dans le cerveau mais j'ai
pas peur pour lui c'est un grand garçon
moi j'ai pas je vous dis moi j'ai peur
de rien donc le on va avoir peur de quoi
moi je veux protéger mes enfants vos
amis et notre métier artistique on est
deux artistes aujourd'hui aux jeunes est
monté sur scène juste le faire notre
métier
jean marie aujourd'hui il le disait il
il a été bloqué sur les ont bloqués ces
vidéos comment il fait pour pour la
pauvre parce qu'il s'est compliqué pour
les artistes selon lui gagner des sous
jean marie c'est un immense artiste
comme il fait avec ses vidéos bloqué en
ce moment c'est ça doit être compliqué
passé vidéo bloqué ça l'ennuie parce
qu'il aime bien communiquer avec son
public c'est
raison pour laquelle il est venu c'est
pour ça qu'il était un peu remonté oui
ça rapporte de l'argent bras mari l'a
jamais trop travaillé pour l'argent mais
bon je sais moi mais bon honnêtement je
vous le dis joue le joueur s'il voulait
de l'argent il en aurait voilà plus même
s'il voulait donc c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui y voit là il aime son
public
il aime le contact avec la scène vous
rendez compte là je parle quand même au
nom de tous les artistes même les
musiciens
voilà les chanteurs les techniciens du
spectacle moi je suis issu du théâtre
on est frustré moi j'ai la chance de
tourner régulièrement non dans plus
belle la vie mais vous vous rendez
compte on peut pas monter sur scène
c'est on est les artistes sont son musée
non ils n'ont plus le contact avec leur
public ils sont en train de dépérir de
mourir à petit feu
c'est terrible ce qu'on leur fait on
pourrait quand même accordé un public de
venir une place sur deux regarde et
comme on est là voilà on pourrait avoir
un siège de libre sur un siège et être
et avoir un masque et les artistes
pourraient monter sur scène dont moi
tout ça très bien d'avoir donné la
parole à jean marie bigard ya tout ça
très bien de donner la parole à toutes
les personnes qui sont à contre courant
c'est marrant parce que depuis des
années on entend qu à la télé on peut
plus rien dire on lui donnait son
opinion est en fait si dans des
émissions comme tpm paix mais aussi les
chaînes info on entend plein de gens
avec l'inde opinions différentes et
c'est très bien
contrairement aux réseaux sociaux qui
sont soit disant le paradis de la
liberté d'expression et on se rend
compte que non puisque elle a été
bloquée donc c'est très bien leur donner
la parole et on essaie de lutter être
contre le fait qu'ils soient bloqués
lola vous lui avez des quoi hier quand
il est rentré à la maison à jean marie
au début j'étais énervé parce que je dis
je n'hésite pas à crier
moi je vous l'avais dit non mais moi je
vous le dis j'aime pas et même sur
d'autres choses même beaucoup plus
intime en tout cas de notre vie commune
depuis maintenant 15 ans j'aime pas
quand il crie il est colérique il est
nerveux quand il a une conviction il a
ce sentiment d'injustice depuis qu'il
est petit et quand il a l'impression
qu'ils vivent injustice il souffrirait
comme un animal et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il ne sait pas s'exprimer
autrement qu'en criant quand vociférant
je lui dis je peux te faire entendre
dans le monde nous avait engueulé un peu
au début mais oui je dit mais je n'en
gagne pas sur le fond il a le droit il a
une liberté d'expression bordel il a le
droit de
ici s'il en veut dire que le ciel et
vert il dit le ciel et vert ça le
regarde mais j'aime pas encore une fois
la manière qu'il a d'avoir une vérité
absolue et on a franchement mais moi y'a
des fois je dis mais qu'est ce que tu as
deux d'où tu sais ça toi tu tiens ça de
qui de quoi
2 ou l'ordi mais j'en suis convaincu bon
ok voilà est-ce que des gens qui étaient
très très pote avec lui et qui lui ont
tourné le dos pas du tout non il n'a pas
on a peu d'amis ce qu'on a on les garde
on les compte sur les doigts de la main
et voilà mais ils vont certainement pas
lui tourner le dos parce qu'il a dépensé
un peu arrêté sur certains sujets
d'accords en tout cas nous sachez le ual
m
jean marie doré qui l'a dire même il
faut à chaque fois on adore ça moi j'ai
beau ne pas être d'accord avec lui sur
beaucoup beaucoup de choses comme ça
restera toujours mon ami et il le sait
et je serai toujours lampy elle droite
s'est questionné on déchire toujours là
pour l'aider il est toujours là pour lui
il le sait jean marie même si on est
voilà on n'est pas d'accord sur plein de
choses ça restera toujours mon ami jean
mazet la série et je lui dis c'est
adorable ce que vous dites et vous
regarder sans les toucher mais vous
savez il n'est pas vraiment quelqu'un a
sauvé en ce moment donc je sais ce que
plus il est comme ça et bien sûr gens
l'aiment c'est terrible c'est pas pour
ça qu'ils le faire et calcule rien mais
plus et vient épais plus il est seul
contre tous et plus il est à
contre-courant et moins y suit une
pensée unique et plus les français qui
sont pas même en ce moment dans un état
de rébellion
ils savent pas vraiment trop con tre
quoi ni contre qui mais je m'inclus même
moi là dedans on est tous dans un état
de rébellion parce qu'on en a marre donc
le il incarne cette rébellion
il salue les gens l'aiment on va voir
combien de téléspectateurs le shérif
sais pas mais avant de passer à huy à
54% et non à 46% au début oui à 54%